cloud computing refers to the practices
storing and accessing data applications
and Computing resources over the
internet instead on local servers or
personal computers it involves the
delivery of various services including
servers storage databases networking
software and analytics through the
internet Cloud this technology enables
organizations and individuals to access
and utilize resources on demand without
the need for significant upfront
infrastructure Investments the global
adoption of cloud computing has
witnessed an exceptional surge in recent
years and the trend is projected to
continue at a remarkable Pace according
to a report by Gartner the worldwide
public cloud services Market is
forecasted to grow by 23.1 percent in
2023 amounting to a staggering 332
billion in Revenue this escalating
demand is driven by factors such as the
need for digital transformation they
data storage requirements increase
mobility and the rising popularity of
software as a service applications with
such rapid growth the demand for skilled
Professionals in cloud computing job
rules is intensifying trading numerous
opportunities for those looking to build
a career in this Dynamic and evolving
field
cloud computing has emerged as a game
changer in the technology landscape
revolutionizing The Way businesses store
process and access data as the demand
for cloud-based Solutions continues to
soar job opportunities in the field of
cloud computing have multiplied offering
exciting career prospects for
professionals with the right skill sets
therefore here I am with this new video
on cloud computing job roles and salary
this video will delve into the various
job roles in cloud computing
highlighting the skills and
certifications required and shedding
light on the attractive salary packages
available in India and the USA so let's
get started but before that do subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the Bell
icon to get notifications on more such
informative videos so let's start first
is cloud architect now Cloud Architects
are responsible for Designing and
implementing Cloud infrastructure
Solutions tailored to meet these
specific needs of organizations the they
possess a deep understanding of cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
Microsoft Azure or Google Cloud as well
as the infrastructure as a service
platform as a service and software as a
service models in addition expertise in
networking security and virtualization
is crucial popular certifications for
cloud Architects include AWS certified
Solutions architect and Microsoft
certified Azure Solutions architect now
if we talk about salary then in India
Cloud Architects earn an average annual
salary ranging from 15 lakh to 35 lakh
and in the U.S the salary ranges from
110 280
000 per year second is cloud developer
now Cloud developers focus on building
applications specifically designed to
run on cloud platforms they possess
strong programming skills with expertise
in languages such as Java python or Ruby
additionally they need to have a
comprehensive understanding of cloud
platforms like AWS Azure or Google Cloud
along with the knowledge of
containerizations Technologies like
Docker and orchestration tools like
kubernetes now if we talk about
certification then relevant
certifications include AWS certified
developer and Microsoft certified Azure
developer in India Cloud developers earn
an average annual salary ranging from 8
lakhs to 20 lakhs and in the USA their
salaries range from 90 000 to 250 000
per year third coming up in the list is
cloud security engineer
now as Cloud technology adoption expands
the demand for skilled professionals to
ensure the security of cloud-based
systems is on the rise Cloud security
Engineers specialize in implementing
robust security measures managing access
controls and safeguarding data and
infrastructure they possess knowledge of
security Frameworks encryption
Technologies identify and access
Management Solutions and compliance
standards certifications like certified
Cloud Security Professionals ccsp and
certified Cloud security specialist
ccss are highly regarded now talking
about salary in India Cloud security
Engineers earn an average annual salary
ranging from 10 lakhs to 25 lakhs and in
the USA this RVs range from one hundred
thousand dollars to hundred and seventy
thousand dollars per year and the last
one in the list is cloud data engineer
now cloud data Engineers play a crucial
role in managing and processing large
volumes of data on cloud platforms they
are proficient in data integration in
like ETL processes data warehousing and
database management skills in Big Data
Technologies such as Apache Hadoop
Apache spark and SQL are advantages
relevant certifications include AWS
certified big data and Google Cloud
certified professional data engineer now
talking about salary in India cloud data
Engineers earn an average annual salary
ranging from 8 lakhs to 222 lakhs and in
the USA the salaries range from hundred
thousand dollars to hundred sixty
thousand dollars per year now to help
you to attain these skills we have
introduced our Caltech cloud computing
bootcamp this course will help you
become an expert in Azure AWS and gcp
and let you master key architecture
principles and develop the skills needed
to become a cloud expert this bootcamp
will help you become an expert in
designing planning and scaling Cloud
implementations it will help you master
the core skill sets required to design
and deploy dynamically skilled available
and reliable applications on completion
of this course you will gain Caltech
cdme certification with 40 plus Hands-On
projects along with opportunities to
secure a job in large companies like
Netflix MasterCard Adobe and more so you
can check out its Link in the
description
and to help you better understand the
impact of cloud computing and a cloud
computing certifications here's a
success stories of one of our Learners
that will help you build your belief and
boost your confidence to master this
technology so let's start
and I am currently living I wanted to
experience what is like to eat I also
realized that to get a new job I needed
to have a personal certification in
cloud computing so last year I started
the postgraduate program in cloud
computing in association with culture
with this course I had the choice to
study while I come to Japan that is how
I got this new job offer with 60 salary
high in Finland I will be leading the
cloud computing unit we cannot wait to
start our new life in Finland we are all
well the field of cloud computing offers
a diverse range of job rules each with
its own set of skills and certifications
as organizations increasingly migrate to
the cloud the demand for cloud
professionals continue to search
Cloud Architects developers security
engineers and data Engineers are just a
few of the rewarding job roles available
in this thriving industry with
attractive salary packages in India and
the USA pursuing a career in cloud
computing can be highly lucrative as the
cloud landscape continue to evolve these
job rules are expected to remain in high
demand providing ample opportunities for
professionals to shape the future of
technology well with this we have come
to the end of this video If you like
this video then please do give it a
thumbs up and share it with your friends
if you have any questions related to
this video then please feel free to ask
away in the comment section our team
will reach out to you as soon as
possible thank you and keep learning
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here